for those Americans who believe in the
perfect body it's largely de creation of
the image factories of Madison Avenue
and this city Los Angeles California
while the women of La have long embraced
plastic surgery now men are stepping up
to the plate signing on for everything
from eyelid surgery and liposuction to
procedures considerably more extreme J
may not look like someone who should
worry about his physique but he's about
to have plastic surgery anyway over the
last five six years I've really worked
on developing my body building my body
up I've gone from 170 pounds to 225
pounds and because of a knee injury I've
not been able to work out my legs as
much as I wanted to but it's not his
legs J wants to enhance surgically its
his behind
so he's opting to have one of the more
major cosmetic procedures available he's
going to get silicone implants in his
buttocks one in each cheek everyone has
their demons to deal with and mine has
to deal with the perception I have of my
body dr. J's buttocks implant surgery
will be done by dr. Alexander Sinclaire
of all the operations dr. Sinclair
performs this is one of the most
invasive the buttocks muscles the
gluteus maximus are the largest in the
human body nation and dr. Sinclair will
have to slice into them to insert the
implants and it's all for a purely
cosmetic effect what he wants is
fullness in the upper buttock the
implant will be placed above this line
in this area the practical change here
is that when J is wearing tight Levi's
or jeans he's going to have a fuller
more robust appearance
throughout the operation Jay will be
just lightly sedated but his lower back
and legs will be completely numb for dr.
Sinclair the primary concern will be
placing the implants in exactly the
right spot there's little room for error
he must steer clear of Jays sciatic
nerves or risk crippling his legs to
create a pocket for the implant he digs
deep below the muscle under the muscle
it just gives that natural contour of
the muscle bulging out and that's really
what the patient is looking for after
two hours the surgery is complete but
for Jay the hardest part still ahead
he's in for plenty of pain as an
infection would mean the implants have
to come out but so far Jay has no
regrets for Jay as for many in LA
plastic surgery is not just a shortcut
for achieving the perfect body it's an
instrument for realizing the far more
individual goal of becoming happier with
who he is